hi I'm Lexi Underwood I'm Gavin Lewis my
name is Megan Stott hi I'm Jordan Elsa
I'm Jade Pettijohn from little fires
everywhere and I'm about to answer some
rapid-fire questions like nervous the
rapid fire I don't know if I know either
of those people explain it
oh they're both so amazing I think like
I'm just so about like getting my
business done but at the same time like
I have a little bit of like Elwood's
love for fashion like where she's like
in the books getting everything done but
like can still look cute while doing it
like Olivia Pope I'm like more of a mix
of they're both so good I'm in Olivia
woods I don't know I really love Olivia
Pope I feel like I really relate to her
but I also love Elle Woods and I look
like woods and everything so that makes
sense - oh okay yeah of course I'm the
second name I recognise never seen
scandal full honesty full disclosure I
seen clips but did see legally blind so
I'll go without what I'm gonna say I'm I
know what's you know definitely see some
traits there I'm dirty blind legally
dirty black I'm a little bit of both I
mean I love Elwood's she's hilarious
and she has that an intellectual side
that not many people see she also is
very funny and she's very flirty and
playful but then at the same time
Kerry's role it is more serious and
sometimes she has those moments but I
think I'm kind of both yeah I think I'm
more of an Olivia Pope for sure
oh my god she's Risa this show my first
impression was she really good she was
super funny she was making jokes unset'
Reese is just she is sunshine like her
production company she's just such a ray
of light then when she first walked into
the table read I was like oh that's
that's Reese Witherspoon I'd watched ray
since I was very very young she's my
idol same thing southern hospitality
sweetest woman I've ever met just
amazing I mean again super professional
never had a bad day and she would just
come in and just brighten up the room
like everybody was just like all eyes on
her because she's just so amazing she's
awesome she's one of the kindest
individuals I've ever met so the first
time I met her I was like I just feel so
warm like she's just so sweet she's just
so sweet so nice and she's such a
fantastic actor and just honestly like
every time I was in scenes with her I
would just get the chills she's
incredible as Lena Richardson it's so
amazing to work off of such a talented
human being because you know as an actor
she changes up her reads which makes my
job super fun when whoo and playing off
of his messing around with their reads
and I always thought I would meet her
and I would like freak out but I didn't
fortunately and I fell in love with her
and she's she's amazing my first
impression of Kerry Washington when I
first met her I actually cried Kerry
Washington is a force of nature
very professional funny I didn't really
know what she'd be like and then I met
her and I was like oh my gosh she's so
sweet she's so nice she's really a
mentor and she really inspired me to do
things on set that I wouldn't normally
do she's so brilliant and powerful and
strong and kind I was in complete awe
over her she's beautiful she gave me one
look in the very first scene I did over
there that was all we had we had no
plans together she looked at me and I in
that look I was like wow she's insanely
talented based on one look
Cary's just I mean she's amazing she's
so sweet just really welcoming and never
had a bad day just never always
consistent I mean she's she's awesome I
was just like so in awe she's so
beautiful and she's so kind and just
like the way that she embraced me and
she was just like such she's such a
genuine human being and so I was just
like in awe of her in all her glory
I read the little fires of her a book
about a year prior when I heard it was
being produced it was so helpful in the
whole process of developing the story
and the character you know I don't know
if it's necessarily written for my
demographic but I absolutely loved it I
was it was thoroughly invested in the
book the whole time I actually read it
after we finished shooting so I kind of
wanted to not see the discrepancies
between the book and the show not that
there are many it's just a little more
in-depth I read the little fires
everywhere book during my second
audition I finished it in one day okay
it's so good there's so good it's such a
good book I loved it
all the characters are so inspiring and
I really connected with Izzie
I play Lexie Richardson and if I could
describe Lexie in one sentence it would
be you think she's something but she's
not she's complex I play moody and I
think moody is somebody that's decided
he's an introvert based on the way his
family has treated him and the way his
siblings act I play easy Richardson and
she easy they're outspoken individual
she's gonna stand up for what she wants
but not at the cost of losing herself
I play trip and trip is there's more
than meets the eye
more than meets the eye I'll show you
that I'll say that I play Pearl Warren
she's creative intelligence and more
aware and articulate than people think
that she is okay my favorite 90s nod
there's so many of them I had a pager
that matched my baby G watch which was
really incredible oh I think my favorite
was the board that Moody's got it's a
Kurt Cobain conspiracy Board of who
actually killed him and that was an
incredibly detailed set piece that was a
ton of fun to look at
I love me like some good mom jeans and
they were just so vintage and so
comfortable and also the pagers I
couldn't like I I didn't the Pearl
didn't have a pager but like I would
play on Jade's pager like oh my gosh
this is so cool because I had no idea
how and my character was also really
obsessed with 9:02 and oh so there's a
lot of Brenda and Dylan references
comparing it to her relationship with
her boyfriend Brian which was kind of
incredible there's a few scenes where
we're all sitting on the couch at our
house the Richardson kids and we're
watching real world and I'd never heard
of the show like no no clue like I got
into 90s music a little bit low Nirvana
a little Stone Temple Pilots you know
what I mean but never had I ever watched
too many 90 shows that I can think of
and real world no idea and I did a
little research and I was like this sure
looks kind of cool
so that I think was the coolest nod that
I can think of because it was just like
what is the show and then I actually got
to discover a cool show from this show
you know so that was cool
that was cool
my reaction when I read the finale I
loved it I was a little surprised but I
I really liked how they ended the show
but I was a little surprised I was happy
but spread it is different and I think
it is beautiful and the writers did such
an amazing job
amazement amazement I haven't seen any
of the episodes yet but like reading the
script just blown away I was like I was
like got goose bumps
I literally got goose bumps I was
sitting there and I was reading it and
honestly jaw drop whole time whole whole
whole script and that was pretty much
every episode though like it's like
cliffhanger at the end and then I'm like
I get to the next one it was it's fun
it's it's gonna be awesome I can't wait
okay the first time I read the script I
was screaming crying jumping up and down
just like I couldn't believe what I had
just read and then filming it was like
mind-blowing I think that you know
anybody that watches the show or just
the finale will have that exact same
reaction it's I have never been so
shocked in my life reading a script when
I got the finale script I was I read it
multiple times it was it's so good it
makes you shake it's just very fiery and
mysterious and good I love it
[Music]